navx israël est alité bah oui c'était
d'essayer une des images les plus folles
les plus connus la téléralité le fameux
non mais à l'eau c'était dans les 11 5
voilà et c'est devenu culte vous l'aimez
bien ma bulle à un joker joker
d'affaires attend les voilà revient on
battra jamais rencontrés je n'ai jamais
vu adacore pas dire si je la touche la
borne basse ces thèmes sa carrière dont
il doit rendre le personnage donné que
bébel avait déjà fait une fois les anges
savait pas trop trop beaux essais en
deuxième saison où ça regardez ça
j'adore vous revoir ces images regardez
c'est n'importe quoi
ces machins trucs personnels dans ce cas
là apparemment c'était aurélie capucine
qui aveuglent shampoing alloue un mais
alors quoi tu es une fille tapote
shampoing allô allô
suspect avoue meurent sauver
tu es une fille tap atx en point c'est
comme si je te dis athénée fida bat
cheveux